Superman dominated an industry women
will just complain I mean I don't know
if that's true about any fans because
there are a lot of men on only fans
the main point is they make the scene I
have no idea why does she talk about
things she does not know that's the
crazy thing she she literally said she
says oh well men make the same and I ask
them like so you you think they make the
same well I don't know well then why why
are you why is her gut reaction to argue
with me instead of seek what is true
it's like she's so blind in her ideology
that I would know 10 times more about
playing at a professional level than she
would yet she's lecturing me and saying
that we should get the equal prize money
as the men even though she knows nothing